on the east side of the hill is the
shanty town of Pamplona Alton just
around the corner is the private
development Castle arenas one of the
most expensive residential areas in Lima
this ten kilometer long wall built three
years ago marks a clear boundary between
the poor and the rich the divide is
becoming more and more visible in Peru
because wealth is increasingly shared
among an elite the rich have benefited
from the country's improving economy
these slum dwellers have not
we don't have running water here there
is no plumbing we don't have anything as
you can see this is not a life water is
in short supply on her side of the hill
keeping a water canister filled for a
month can cost almost a week's earnings
many residents have come from the
countryside seeking a better life for
themselves and their children
I hope it's better for them not like it
was for us people here subsist on less
than ten solis a day around two and a
half euros that puts them among the
poorest in the country hardly any of
Pamplona zidon sever been on the other
side of the wall I saw houses they're
really big once all the way up to there
I've never been over there husband he
worked there once for two weeks but not
everyone can get in there he says you
have to be registered the wealthy
inhabitants of Casa wariness are
concerned about security and they are
willing to pay a monthly fee to keep
their neighborhood apart
according to one NGO the neighboring
slum is one of limas most dangerous
districts